thank you for being here tonight the
palacio family
contacted me last week after the plea
hearing
for jose rangel and they were in shock
and complete disbelief at the light
sentence
that jose rangel is facing
i'd like to remind the community
who jose rangel is jose rangel
not only did he allow
a murder to happen in his house
but jose rangel helped his son
drag leslie's lifeless body
out of his house into eric's truck
watching eric drive away with leslie's
body
knowing exactly what his son did
knowing exactly that his son had just
committed murder
jose rangel was the last person to have
contact
with eric
and today he only faces a maximum
of two years in two years
this man will be out on our streets
this is extremely scary this is
unfair this family needs justice
they lost their daughter they lost their
sister
they lost their family member and in two
years
jose rangel will be out on the streets
while they're still missing leslie while
leslie is gone
and eric rangel is out on the streets
where is the justice we're asking law
enforcement
we're asking the state we're asking the
community to come together
and bring this family justice two
years two years for helping his son
commit a murder in his house
not only did he drag leslie's lifeless
body
out of his own house but after
he washed his driveway washed leslie's
blood off of his driveway he knew about
this he was part of this
two years is what he faces
we need your help you guys want to say
something
[Music]
[Music]
would you mind
uh basically what she was saying is that
here in vegas there's a lot of criminals
they go to jail for drugs
and they get more time for that and jose
is
a part of a crime that is murder
and he just gets two years and that's
not justice at all
eric eric killed
a friend a sister a successful person
that was trying to achieve her goals
and now she's not a part of our
community no more
all i all i really want is justice to be
served
to put more time but right now we're not
getting that
we're trying so hard
on friday we're going to do a protest
at the cdc clark county detention center
where jose is currently at
right now i'm hoping that a lot of
people would
come and join us and support us so that
we could put more time and
hopefully justice will be served as
quick as possible and
i want every grand girl
to be turning himself in because
right now we're just suffering and we're
we have no words to say
it's very difficult knowing that the
accused killer is still out there
even though his father's been you know
arrested charged
we're extremely scared for our lives to
be going outside
knowing that he's out there probably in
mexico california wherever he's at
we really want him to turn himself in
because that's the only way we want
we could get justice
thank you very much thank you i'd like
to add
that a two-year sentence such a light
sentence would only be justified if jose
rangel
was cooperating with the law enforcement
and the state
and gave his where his son's whereabouts
and eric rangel was in custody or
custody right now
that would be the only justification for
such a light sentence
if eric rangel was in custody right now
thank you
did you guys get notice from the
prosecutor that this is going to happen
did they come to you guys and say this
is a plea deal we have reached
what are your feelings you have any idea
before it was reported was said last
weekend
they did not reach a plea agreement he
just pled guilty to the charges that he
was charged with what we're asking for
is for the state to charge him with
more charges and not face such a light
sentence
we have no contact with the other
members of the family the other members
of the family are out there
and we have no idea where they're at and
they're just living their lives like
nothing
handed down uh are you sure that he
won't get more time
per nevada statue that is what he's
facing is a maximum of two years
so during sentencing he could get a year
he could get a year and a half
but he cannot get more than two years
for the family obviously nothing
you know will unfortunately bring leslie
back but for you what does justice look
like
for me
honestly getting
a life sentence for eric when he turns
himself in
like a life sentence possibly the death
penalty
a life sentence for the father as well
because
eric didn't just kill a monster ever
killed my sister
a successful person eric is
i really want him to get life in prison
with a chance of the death uh a pen uh
the death penalty i also want jose rango
to get
a life sentence as well
yeah a heavy or a heavier sentence
i i honestly don't have that much words
to say i'm really sorry but
we just don't think two years would
justify
such a horrendous act being part of a
murder
just does not make sense so somebody
could help another person commit a
murder
destroy the evidence and only do two
years
in prison and be back out on the streets
who is he going to help
next how likely is it that more charges
will be
brought against him have you guys been
working or pushing or talking with any
officials to
see if that's responsibility where this
is
our cry for help
and do you have any more details about
the plan for friday the time
what's gonna happen uh well basically
we're just going to
go to the cdc
and we're going to basically
march from there to the justice court
to try to at least you know convince
uh you know the jury is the judge to put
jose more time and you know that
we're trying our best to you know
put him a heavier sentence but
the protest is going to be at 3 30
you know will provide a lot of water you
know
and um i just really hope that a lot of
people would come
to you know come support us and just try
to like
put him a heavier sentence
if this sticks just two years or
whatever he gets sticks
will you guys advocate in the future for
future families so that maybe
uh these walls are changed and that have
your sentences
worked out absolutely absolutely that is
exactly the goal that we are going to be
working towards
is that crimes like this do not are not
justified by such light sentences
[Music]
um
see
um